a lot of people are making a lot of
money keeping you
afraid of the wuflu but you don't just
need to take my word for it you can hear
it from a cnn technical director
himself who was caught on hidden camera
thanks to james o'keefe and project
veritas
sand news doesn't do well with ratings
you know like
if you can get someone in passion
that does really well with rated sad
news
back to back to back doesn't do really
well unless
it affects them directly coveted
gangbusters are very
great right which is why we constantly
have a death toll on the side which i
have a major problem with that we're
tallying how many people died every day
because i've even looked at it and be
like
look at him be like let's make it higher
like why isn't it high enough you know
today
like it would make our point better if
it was higher and i'm like what am i
rallying for that's a problem
yeah we're doing that you know like this
special red phone right here yeah
and they pick it up and it's like they
had a network being like
there's nothing that you're doing right
now that makes me want to stick
put the numbers back up because that's
the most
enticing thing that we had this poor
schlub got caught on the sting
i think this was at like a tinder date
or something like that
but he told the truth and he's not even
it's not even him admitting i'm a
terrible person
he's saying i i feel bad about this but
this is what the network wants
because this is how the network is going
to make a lot of money by manipulating
you and they're not the only ones
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from aslan mitchell
who says
if i had a dollar for every time michael
plugs his book speechless controlling
words controlling minds
i would be able to buy acre gold bars in
bulk while sitting in my ex chair that
is true
does it count as a plug if i'm reading
somebody else
telling me about the book does that
count
it okay it does all right i'm gonna talk
i'll have to dispute this with the
producers after the show because i feel
it's not as though i
brought that up but it is true that the
book is available now
for pre-order uh and i hope you enjoy
that i hope you're feeling good i hope
you're feeling
healthy and well and excited for the
book one great way to feel healthy and
well
nutrisystem nutrasystem is simple and
convenient with delicious meals
delivered right to your door
with little to no meal prep required
that means
no shopping in busy grocery stores with
nutrisystem you can lose up to 18 pounds
in your first two months
the plan is clinically proven to put
your body in fat burning mode and helps
you achieve
safe and healthy weight loss nutrasystem
helps you lose weight
and learn how to keep it off they have a
top rated app called nume
for extra motivation to help you stay on
track you get
unlimited one-on-one coaching order
nutrasystem
now go to nutrasystem.com to get 50
off that is nutrasystem.com the thing i
really love about these guys
it is uh really good tasting stuff so
i've got friends who go on these crash
diets you know and they'll only eat one
type of thing for six months and they
lose a lot of weight and then what do
they do they gain it all back it's
probably not the healthiest way to do it
nutrisystem you don't have to worry
about that craziness you're going to be
eating good meals they're balanced they
will help you
take some weight off nutrisystem right
now go to nutrasystem.com to get 50
off a lot of people making a lot of
money hyping up
the woof flu but it's not just about the
money it's not just about cynical
corporations
squeezing another dollar out of
sensationalism that's the story of
journalism
there is a political agenda here there
is an ideological agenda
the corporate media are making a lot of
money
the politicians are amassing a lot of
power but it's all on the same sort of
thing
libs in the government are hoping to
inflate the covid numbers
this is not some crazy conspiracy theory
this is a simple matter of incentives
chuck schumer and aoc have just
announced a new program
to give nine thousand dollars
to the family members of people who have
died
from covid and if your family member
doesn't have kovid listed as the cause
of death on the certificate don't worry
they say you can have it added after the
fact
today is the day the hotline is open
and because that hotline is open you can
call into fema and you can start this
process today
now we know here in new york how
tough those early days were we couldn't
even get
tests here early on it was something
that was for
celebrities and the privileged in those
very early days
and so we we have been senator schumer
and i have been working with fema
we've been on the phone trying to get as
flexible and accommodating circumstances
as possible
so here's what families need to know
your loved one should have
covid on their death certificate
anywhere
listed on their death certificate either
as the primary or contributing cause
of death in those early days though we
know
that so many people we didn't know what
was coveted and what wasn't
and so there are several options
available here one
is that you can go back to the
institution that issued the death
certificate the hospital
the physician etc and you can have your
death certificate edited
in retrospect knowing what we know now
about covet
this is so so clever it's not the first
time we've heard from the beginning
of the pandemic that there were lots of
different incentives
for hospitals and public health
officials
to inflate the numbers you've heard
stories of certain numbers actually
being corrected down upon second glance
but through certain policies like
providing extra funding
for hospitals based on the number of
covid patients they had
uh classifying anybody who died with
covid is dying of covid so if you
have covid and you have no symptoms
because you're a healthy person and
you're young and you just
you don't even know you have it then you
get shot in the head
you go to the hospital they test you for
cova they say yeah it's a covid death
right so obviously these are some
perverse incentives to really tick up
those numbers
and now aoc and schumer who they might
not be the most
philosophically astute people they might
not be the the most capacious minds ever
but they are shrewd politicians and they
know
that if you dangle nine grand out in
front of people's families and you say
you know all you got to do call up that
hospital say your loved one died of
covid
they know that those numbers are going
to go up why does it benefit them if
those numbers go up one it creates the
sense of crisis
the numbers are all going down just like
cnn says what are we going to do now
so you know we've lost our ratings now
that kovit is on the way out we need
something to jin people up
the same is true for politicians who who
especially on the left will never let a
crisis go to waste
so they've got to continue the sense of
urgency this is something that
progressives
do generally according to the
progressive view of history the past is
always terrible
and the present is always a crisis and
the future is always going to be perfect
and wonderful
so you got it you're in that crisis and
you've got to harness that kind of
energy and
anxiety to bring us into that utopian
future and that is
certainly what aoc and chuck schumer are
doing and they're doing it to great
effect and republicans
don't really know how to counter it they
just don't know
how to fight that kind of sophistication
in politics speaking of dishonestly
inflating numbers this is an unrelated
story
generally but it
there is one connection at least bernie
madoff died
bernie made off the most famous ponzi
schemer
in history including ponzi bernie madoff
defrauded countless people
to the tune of i don't know what
zillions and zillions of dollars
he's he is the most fame infamous
fraudster in american history he was
serving 150 year sentence
and he died in prison at i believe 82.
the reason i mention this who cares you
know bernie madoff is dead
okay that's fine i actually know someone
who met bernie madoff once in prison
and he was going and conducting an
interview and he said the guy didn't
have a hint of remorse
so i don't know one can pray for
bernie's bernie's soul
but i'm i i'm not sure it's looking
great for him
the reason i bring it up is to remind
you
that there are limits to our politics
we on on the left they believe there's
no limit
to self-actualization
to individual autonomy in the social
realm so
there should be no limits on who we
sleep with
how we view the country what property we
can take how we burn things down there
should be no limits whatsoever
on our base desires and then on the
right
we have the flip side of that coin which
is there should be no limits whatsoever
on my freedom of choice in the
marketplace for instance or something
like that
my freedom of speech we now say we're
free speech absolutists even though
conservatives have never believed that
sort of thing until about five minutes
ago
fraud is not protected speech
when you defraud somebody you are not
engaging in
an act of speech that is protected by
the first amendment never has been
i hope it never will be there are limits
to the first amendment we know that
there are limits to the first amendment
obscenity
sedition fighting words
threats and fraud most especially dante
puts the fraudsters
in just about the lowest circle of hell
right right above the the traitors to
their benefactors you have the
fraudsters
why so this issue is a little bit
personal for me in that i have a
relative who was
essentially killed by a fraudster this
relative was defrauded
by a criminal you know by a con artist
and this
the stress of this and and the
devastation basically killed my relative
that speech cannot be
protected you do not have the right to
dishonest deceitful duplicitous speech
and we're not just seeing that on the
level of bernie madoff
we are seeing that on a whole political
level we're not it's not even just about
cnn
trying to gin up the ratings or
something it's about an
organized movement in this country on
the left
to disregard truth not saying
they're even lying i'm saying they have
no concern for the truth whatsoever
they believe as the leftist
intellectuals from the mid 20th century
believed
that there basically is no such thing as
truth that it's all just words words
words that everything is socially
constructed that our
very sex our human nature is socially
constructed and it can be whatever we
say that it is and so if i tell a lie on
the left
but i believe it's for a good social
purpose if i defraud people even
but i believe it's for a good social
purpose then
that's the moral thing to do and that is
just not true the moment we
we exalt fraud in this country one of
the greatest sins you can possibly
commit
is the the moment that we will really
really have lost
our country when i think of who's
committing the most fraud around here it
probably it would be
the the militant radicals on the street
i'm talking about the leftist
terrorists burning down our country
notably blm
because they are torching our country on
a lie
you know i'm talking about in a very
narrow sense the
the blm riots have been
called the 1619 riots by charles kessler
at the claremont review
and hannah nicole jones or nicole hannah
jones whatever her name is
she said she was proud to call the blm
riots the 1619 riots the 1619 project
which says that america's
the revolution took place basically
because of slavery
to protect slavery that is a that is
fraud that is a lie
that the central thesis of that is not
true
it's been debunked by academic
historians but the left doesn't care
because he's an italian expression
if it's not true it makes a good story
and it's a makes a useful story for them
and so they are going to push that fraud
even if it means torching the country do
not
do that sort of thing we like having
brick and mortar stores up but we don't
always like going into those brick and
mortar stores to get auto parts that's
why you got to check out
rock auto rockauto.com is so much
easier than walking into a store and
someone demanding quick answers to
things like is your odyssey an lx or an
ex
and then they usually just have to order
the part online anyway because there are
so many types of cars it's impossible
to keep them all stocked you have access
to rockauto.com
at your desk and in your pocket the
rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever
need head on over to rockauto.com do not
subject yourself
to that indignity of not knowing what
parts you're supposed to get for your
car
and then they don't have it and they
charge you twice as much go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck write knolls in there how did
you hear about his box
so they know we sent you speaking of
fraud and big money
patrice cullers the executive director
of black lives matter's
global network foundation says that
she is now denying charges that we
reported on a few days ago
that she is going on a spending spree
buying up nice mansions for herself
blm has been redubbed black lives
manners
or to some people by large mansions
she's coming out she's denying this
entirely
she says she doesn't even get paid she
says she's received a total of 120
000 since the organization's inception
in 2013
for duties such as serving as spokesman
engaging in political education work
she hasn't received a penny after 2019.
now she's saying it's a right-wing
offensive that's putting her and her
family at risk
and it continues a tradition of terror
by white supremacists against black
activists
the lady doth protest too much methinks
i don't believe her i don't believe that
she hasn't been paid in two years
for her job i don't believe that these
reports
are just completely fabricated out of
nowhere and by the way
black lives matter of new york city
doesn't believe her either hawk newsom
is the leader of blm in new york city
has called for an independent
investigation into
patrice culler's finances and operations
of the blm group says quote if you go
around calling yourself a socialist
you have got to ask how much of her own
personal money is going to charitable
causes
it's really sad because it makes people
doubt the validity of the movement
and overlook the fact that it is the
people that carry
this movement okay so now there's
infighting among blm
love that totally love that but i don't
think it's really an earnest
i wish that all of a sudden blm really
cared about the truth
but i don't think that they do i think
that blm
is basically fighting within its own
factions
over who's going to get the money this
happened in ferguson when blm raked in
something like 90 million dollars last
year you heard the family of michael
brown you heard the the ferguson blm
activists they said hey wait a minute
this isn't fair
you got to cut us in on it we want a
little taste not that this is wrong to
be raising all this money for these
dubious political causes no they just
said hey give me a cut
and i suspect that's what blm is doing
here that is a really basic
politics okay that is really
dirty bare-knuckle politics
and the left is much better at it than
republicans there there is a question
right now as to whether or not some
republicans are engaging in this
matt gates is at the center of one of
these
issues we talked about it a little bit
last week
matt gates he's being he's saying that
he's being extorted by someone people
are accusing him of sleeping with
teenage girls
who knows or i guess there'll be some
investigation regardless of the truth of
it
cnn is now admitting that they're going
to hype this
because they want to go after matt gates
oh no hi guys yes okay can you define
happy ending like i think i know but
like
how is it um what's the mechanism
if the agenda say is to like get
like matt gates right now he's like this
republican
he's a problem for the democratic party
because he's so conservative
and he can cause a lot of hiccups in
passing applause
so it's
it would be great for them so we're
going to keep
running those stories to keep hurting
him and make it so that he can't be
buried and like
just you know settled outside of court
and just like you know
if we keep pushing them it's helping us
that's propaganda it's helping us in
some way
it is of course and that that is the
motivation for why they keep running all
these matt gates stories is because they
feel that matt gates is an effective
communicator and
they want to go after him so it's not
about i don't know whether matt gates
did what he's accused of doing or
whether he's being extorted or whether
whatever
that is secondary to
the narrative because the left knows
that the narrative is very helpful so
they're going to continue to repeat it
so bringing this back
to the racial grievance industry like
the blm people
bringing this back to the race hustlers
you're going to see more
and more narratives about racial hatred
on camp on campus especially
even if the left has to contrive the
metaphor cloth great example of this
last week students of color what color i
don't know
at white bear lake high school south
campus in minnesota were invited into a
group chat on instagram
where they were sent threatening and
racist messages
oh man this is a big deal these you know
classic white supremacists in high
schools
are going in threatening these students
and
this is going to be a big school-wide
issue and then oh wait a second nope
never mind
never mind it's okay no big deal nothing
to see here let's move on why
because it appears to have been a hoax
i could have told you i couldn't have
told you with 100 certainty that this
was a hoax
but i would have i would have bet a lot
of money that it was a hoax
i actually detail countless examples of
this
in my upcoming book speechless available
now for pre-order which is
that on issues of race on issues of sex
you hear again and again and again the
racist there was a
burning cross there was a swastika
painted there was the n-word painted all
over
people's dorms oh it was a hoax oh it
was fake oh
they made it up themselves the same
thing is true of the
the alleged campus rape epidemic time
and time and time again
how many high profile examples do we
need going back to the duke lacrosse
case
of hoaxes here why why are there hoaxes
because they know
the left knows that the narrative is
extraordinarily valuable and victimhood
carries social currency so if you create
incentives for that sort of thing
you're going to get a whole lot more of
it
that's that's the way the business works
that's the way grievance incorporated
works
and if you create incentives in the
other direction towards say
virtue humility resignation
courage all of these virtues prudence
then you will get more of that as well
why are these students
creating the hoaxes it's not even just
the student's fault it's not that
they're
total fraudsters i mean they are they
are fraudsters but it's not that this
came out of nowhere it's because that is
how they're being educated that is the
indoctrination that they're
they're getting in school from a very
young age it's what they're being taught
the santa clara county office of
education
just uh gave a presentation to educators
that had to have these struggle sessions
how to indoctrinate children in this
ridiculous racial ideology
uh the the presenter here was a guy
named jorge pacheco
and this comes to us via chris ruffo at
city journal
this is what the presenter told the
teachers quote we have to be extra
careful
about what is being said since we can't
just say something controversial now
that we're in people's homes
parents can take out of context or see
what materials are being used
so we need to be careful of what they
see
the kids become a subject and you are
intending to awaken them to the
oppression
that they aren't aware of but that they
are actively participating in
then how to lead to social change wow
this is
out of a cartoon that this guy would say
this one
our education is so radical that you
have to hide it from parents
the implication here parents should have
absolutely no say in how their children
are raised only we the radicals who have
taken over
the instruments of the state only we
should have a say in that
and three false consciousness
this is an idea that was developed by
the neo-marxists
after it comes from the idea of marx
that that basically you have to awaken
the proletariat
the working classes the oppressed masses
to their own oppression
uh because they turns out that the
working classes tended to have some
common sense and they didn't go for the
radicals crazy theories
so then beginning with people like
antonio gramsci
the italian marxist philosopher and
communist politician the frankfurt
school
later on the new left which was led by
one of the chief figures from the
frankfurt school
you see this idea really flowering
during the second wave of feminism in
the 1970s
when people would have struggle sessions
no different than the kind of
indoctrination people are getting their
workplaces or in their schools right now
where i kid you not
women especially would go into these
struggle sessions they'd feel happy
they'd love their family
they you know maybe they'd bring a
little uh tupperware of
some delicious treat they made right and
they go they go into the struggle
session
and they leave extremely irritated and
angry and resentful
because they had been made aware of
their own oppression there's a very
famous
essay i also detailed this in my book
there's a very famous essay called
called the personal is political by
carol hanish this is credited with
really epitomizing the second wave of
feminism
where they celebrate this where these
women celebrate going to the wine and
cheese soirees w-h-i-n-e
and they would go and they'd say oh i'm
so glad that i'm
angry now i used i was so happy before
this and i loved my family but i'm so
glad now
that you radical feminists have given me
this resentment made me aware of my
oppression
that is exactly the same thing that this
presenter and the santa clara county
office of education is doing they're
saying we need to awaken
children to their own resentments if
they're not
resentful already we need to instill
resentment in them
only that way can we have revolution
not ever working on yourself just always
projecting onto the rest of society if
you do want to work on yourself though
you got to check out
total gym the total gym fit gives me a
full body workout in the comfort of my
home for about half the price
of those expensive fitness bikes you can
do
over 85 exercises on one machine whether
you're a beginner or advanced they have
everything you need to get in the best
shape
of your life burn calories and lose
weight
what makes it so effective is that it
works every muscle group using 12 levels
of resistance you can work your core
arms shoulders biceps thighs
your whole body and a complete workout
takes just 10 to 20 minutes a day
you know me i'm not a hulking adonis but
this is a great really simple way
for a quick way to to get in shape and
to start looking like chuck norris and
christy brinkley which is what i'm after
right now total gym is offering a 30-day
in-home trial on the total gym fit for
just one dollar
that's it just one dollar what do you
have to lose no matter which total gym
you try my listeners can get an
additional 20
off whatever discount they're currently
running head on over to
totalgymdirect.com
knowles to get this special offer you
have to go to this url
knowles to get an additional 20 off you
know ben is going to be talking about
this from the presidential level today's
gonna be talking about
why team biden thinks america is just
terrible
also be sure to check out the candace
show it's already episode five no one
can get enough candace owens and her new
show candace so head on over check it
out
this fearless conservative leader hosts
a lively series of guests each week
for a discussion panel interviews and
her signature cancel corner
if you look not that closely you'll see
a giant picture of my head there
from when that razor company tried to
cancel me uh this week
she will be hosting the comedian and
podcaster adam corolla tune in
because you will not want to miss their
conversation the show streams on
fridays at 9 00 pm eastern 8 p.m central
at dailywire.com
but you can get the audio podcast canvas
on apple spotify or wherever
you listen to your podcast so if you
need some camera zones in your life head
on over
look no further check out apple
podcaster spotify subscribe today be
sure to leave a 5 star review
we'll be back with a lot more
it's not just the radical leftists who
are upending
our culture it's not it's not just the
radical leftists who are
destroying our american way of life it
is the
neo-liberal centrists as well
this is why you know sometimes you'll
hear people say well i'm a liberal but
i'm not a leftist
okay i guess that's better i guess it's
better to be a sort of squishy lib
rather than a communist
but ultimately it's all going in the
same direction
if you want to conserve stuff then you
got to conserve stuff give you
this great example though a bloomberg
writer
uh just published an op-ed and said
that basically we if we want to stop the
immigration crisis
we need to outsource all of our jobs he
writes quote
the best way to grow central american
economies and thus put an
end to asylum crises once and for all is
to give companies
incentive to locate factories and
offices in central america
protectionists aren't going to like that
yeah people who like their own country
aren't going to like that's what i guess
that's what they mean by protectionists
people who think that the american
government
and american companies ought to
prioritize
american citizens over foreign nationals
yes that's true we're not going to like
that
well well you understand michael if you
if we don't outsource all of our jobs to
these third world countries
why then we're gonna get lots and lots
of people just coming into our country
illegally
okay so yeah that's bad we definitely
don't want people to be doing that
what if we though and i'm i'm just
totally spitballing here
what if in order to fix this border
crisis
what if we just don't let him in but
michael they're they're
seeking asylum from political
persecution first of all
no they're not they're not they're not
they're economic migrants
who if they were really fleeing
political persecution from guatemala or
el salvador or honduras
could stop in any of the countries
between their country and the united
states stop in mexico live there have a
good life
no well no they'd be better let's go a
little bit further let's go
to that really good country called
america okay they're not seeking asylum
in
very very rare cases are they actually
seeking asylum what they're really
seeking is
better jobs and economic opportunity
okay
sure i get it i probably want that too
but we can't take in the entire world
because then we don't have a country so
that part easy well but michael
if we hold on a second if we don't let
them
just come into the country then they
might they'll just cross illegally
okay i hear you i hear that objection uh
so maybe we could again write
this is just off the top of my head
arrest and deport them what if we do
that what if they come into the country
illegally
and then we pass
measures that require employers for
instance to prove that their employees
are citizens
we do not permit foreign nationals to
access
our very generous public welfare systems
we don't allow
illegal aliens to vote like the
democrats want
what if we create incentives for
criminal aliens
whose first act in this country is to
break one of our most basic laws
what if we create incentives for them
not to come over and to leave once
they've come over
but michael the that would be i
seriously this guy one of these guys who
who wrote this op-ed
he responded to me he said that would
create a pr
nightmare for
whom pr nightmare
by whose standards if i saw a lot of
headlines saying
america actually enforcing our southern
border america
turning away the hordes of economic
migrants trying to pour over it
america deporting criminal aliens in our
country
that i i think that would be a pr win i
would be very happy to read those
headlines
i think most americans would be happy to
read those headlines
according to surveys not that long ago
harvard-harris poll
the majority of americans that includes
democrats too
want to reduce drastically not just
illegal immigration but also legal
immigration seems like that would be a
huge pr win but not a pr win
for neo-liberal rationalists who don't
really have
very much affection for their country
who don't think that nationalism is kind
of an ugly thing
they're citizens of the world they come
on they'll be fine they can go work
anywhere
these bloomberg riders they didn't bring
their laptop they can be on a beach
somewhere in bali it doesn't matter
people who rely on those manufacturing
jobs well that's too bad but hey you
know learn to code
learn to code that's not the radical
left that is the establishment that is
the liberal establishment
the whole thing including and especially
big business
i don't know i don't know about you
but when i sit down i want to relax i
want to indulge a little bit
i open up a pint of ice cream i don't
want my ice cream
to call me a white supremacist that's i
don't ask a lot of my ice cream i ask
for it to be
cold a little bit soft sweet maybe have
some little chocolate chips in it and
not call me a white supremacist
but that would be too much to ask from
ben
jerry's so ben and jerry's yesterday
famously a liberal brand or a leftist
brand
they tweet out quote the murder of dante
wright
is he's the guy who was shot by the
woman cop while he was
under arrest for a weapons charge and
then he fled
the the murder of dante wright is rooted
in white supremacy
and results from the intentional
criminalization
of black and brown communities this
system can't be reformed
it must be dismantled and a real system
of public safety
built from the ground rebuilt from the
ground up
uh none of that is true but more to the
point and i i cannot stress this enough
this is coming from ice cream nothing
they said is true it's
no evidence that he was murdered and no
evidence it was rooted in white
supremacy
no evidence that we ought to dismantle
the entire legal system in this country
moreover it's not even those two hippies
who's founded the company
ben jerry's is owned by a multinational
corporation called unilever
with annual revenue upwards of 60
billion dollars
why do we tolerate this why do we
tolerate a multinational corporation
coming into our country trying to
undermine our entire legal order
they are saying right here you need to
upend the entire american legal order
why do we tolerate that
we should we should punish them for that
it is not conservative
to to allow giant multinational
corporations with 60 billion dollars in
revenue
to undermine our whole constitutional
republic nothing conservative at all
but michael the free market yeah okay
great
great how long is that market going to
remain free with radicals like this
using american freedom to undermine
american freedom probably not very long
we are told michael you're you
conservatives you're worried about
slippery slopes
you're told come on forget about these
slippery slopes well jen's hockey was
just asked about
a particular slippery slope uh she was
asked by a great reporter out there
about the biden administration's stance
on
abortion great question listen to the
answer
why does the biden administration insist
that pro-life americans
pay for abortions and violate their
conscience
well first that's not an accurate
depiction of what happens so let me
and i know we want to be accurate around
here none of the funds appropriated
under this title shall be used in
programs where abortion is a method of
family
planning that is written into the public
health service act and it specifically
states that indirect subsidies money
that's fungible that can't be traced we
know that come on
that is not how it works that is the law
so i'm stating what the law is and how
it is implemented legally by these
organizations and the reason i though
since you gave me the opportunity
the reason why the president took these
steps is because
he believes that advancing equity for
all
including people of color and others who
have been historically underserved
marginalized and adversely affected by
persistent poverty
and inequality can be helped by these
actions and by focusing on advancing
equity
in the title 10 program we can create
opportunities for the improvement of
communities that have been historically
underserved
well the community that's most
historically underserved are these
babies who are being killed and even on
the racial grievance front
it's specifically little black babies
who are disproportionately being
attacked
so she completely ignores the question
she
she denies basic facts of money for
instance right she says no no money is
going
to this sort of thing and the reporter
says well you know money is fungible so
this is why it was always so ridiculous
when people would say
the federal government isn't giving
money to abortion
is the federal government giving money
to planned parenthood yes is planned
parenthood
an abortion mill yes so the federal
government's giving money to abortion no
because they're only the money the
federal government's given that's only
going toward the pens and the pencils
and the copy machines
well that's not how money works money is
fungible so you just get money and you
put it in a bank account you don't say
okay but this
dollar has to go here or there
reminder that the conservatives who have
worried about the slippery slope who
have voiced opinions about this have
been called kooks and
hysterics from for decades now they were
right about everything and they continue
to be right about everything
and what the the left is hoping is that
they can just run out the clock on us
they say look we
we just have to we have to open the
border we have
we have to outsource the american jobs
we have to kill babies
in the womb we have to give money to
kill babies and we have to
redistribute all that we have to it's
just this is the science
it's the science of progress it's the
science of history
we don't have to the reason those things
are happening
is because there's big money and big
political power at play and it's a money
grab and it's a power grab but we can
try to take some of that back try to
take
some that money back and some of that
power back from the woke corporations
who are undermining our country
from the radicals who are undermining
our country from within the government
from from the public health
administration which has now become the
established church of the united states
another slippery slope example
headline comes out yesterday in the
technology review mit technology review
scientists plan to drop the 14-day
embryo rule which is a key limit on stem
cell research
so what is this rule there is an ethical
limit under which quote scientists have
agreed never to allow human embryos to
develop beyond two weeks
in their labs that is the point at which
a spherical embryo starts to form a body
plan
which is deciding where the head will
end up and when the cells begin
taking unspecialized missions
i bet many people didn't even know that
scientists do this that scientists
permit the development of little human
beings to perform experiments on them
for two weeks and then they kill them
and that is horrifying enough
but now what they're doing is they're
just going to ditch that rule and
they're going to let them grow and
there's going to be a separate cast of
babies
poor unfortunate babies who are going to
be grown for the pleasure
of perverts and psychopaths in lab coats
to try to improve their own lives
not the lives of the babies they will be
killed when they're no longer useful
this is as ghastly a turn of events as
can possibly happen
and it's not inevitable it's not part of
the inevitable march of science and
progress we can just stop it we can pass
laws against this
and it is this is not an overreach of
government
this is not anti-concern it is very
conservative
to prevent these psychos and lab coats
from performing experiments on human
babies that they will now allow to grow
without limit without any sort of
ethical guideline
we need to really rethink what does it
mean to be a conservative
and if the squishes don't want to come
along i don't want them
liz cheney one of the most
sickening members of congress i don't
know how else to put it
sickening so
contemptuous of her own party so
transparent in where her principle
such as it is really lies she was asked
on neil cavuto's show he said hey
if trump is the nominee in 2024
would you let's i'm not saying you're
going to support him in the primaries
i'm not saying you like the guy
if he were the nominee though versus
some insane leftist democrat like kamala
harris or somebody
would you vote for him over that radical
democrat
guess her answer if donald trump were
the 2024 nominee
would you support him i would not
okay liz cheney there it is she would
not
this woman is in a minor leadership
position in the gop but a leadership
position nonetheless
so you got the left the left is now
openly uh not just raising our taxes
that they're going to do that
calling to pack the supreme court to add
four justices to it they're preparing a
bill to do that right now
but but the constitutional norms they
tell us
when trump sends a tweet now they're
gonna completely upbeam the supreme
court
they are they've turned washington dc
into something resembling downtown
fallujah or baghdad
maybe maybe that's why liz cheney likes
it so much
looks let's talk about a coup it sure
looks like a coup in washington dc right
now
they are now openly advocating the
chemical castration of children for
their social engineering purposes
they are advocating they are defending
the burning down of our cities through
the terrorist organization blm
they are supporting subsidies for
abortion and now they're experimenting
on little babies who can grow with that
end and liz cheney says that's great
that's i'm not yeah okay i'm gonna also
i would rather support
that than vote for the orange man
why because i guess she hates him and
she's gonna make her pride
an idol and she's going to vote more on
the basis of her pride than any
principle or anything good for the
country or because she doesn't actually
care about any of that stuff
or because she is just what what i've
called on the show
a a court jester conservative
she is a liberal who sort of pretends to
be a conservative on certain minor
issues
and in so doing legitimizes the dominant
liberal regime
either way really bad stuff that this
woman has a position
in gop leadership
amazon is pulling another book
off its shelves only a matter of time
before amazon pulls my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds off
i just wanted to hear the bell ring
again they're pulling another one you
you remember
a few weeks ago maybe it was a month ago
at this point ryan anderson's
hilariously titled book when harry
became sally
responding to the transgender moment
that was pulled off of amazon very
quietly amazon didn't really give an
answer as to why that was done
the reason for that we all realize is
because the book
presents a very sober case to challenge
the dominant leftist narrative
on sex and the leftist religious view
on human nature which is now gnostic
dualism the idea that my body has
nothing to do with who i really am
there's another book on the same issue
desist detrans
and detox getting your child out of the
gender cult by maria kefler
who while we're plugging books i guess i
i guess i have to read her book because
if it's considered that dangerous by the
liberal regime
it's probably a pretty good book amazon
is not the government
so you're going to hear some squishes
some court jester conservatives say hey
it's
amazon's private company build your own
amazon yeah they're responsible for
something like 80
of the books sold in the world yeah they
just dominate the marketplace
they they exert a totally outsized
influence on the economy
but private company can't do anything
come on you know build your own twitter
build you're on youtube
build your own parallel government of
woke corporations
to use the term of mitch mcconnell even
mitch mcconnell even an
establishmentarian like mcconnell
recognizes the threat that this poses
it's kind of weird isn't it some people
say you can still order
mineconf on amazon but you can order
these books that are very soberly taking
a look at the transgender issue right
because the left is not threatened by
mineconf though right
the left is not threatened by adolf
hitler actually they benefit from
keeping hitler at top of mind so they
can call all their opponents nazis
they are threatened by
serious common-sense arguments that
expose their ridiculous ideology for
what it is so they're going to ban it
they're pulling that book
why well it's just that's their standard
by the way i'm not totally again as i've
i think i've made this point pretty
clear
i'm not totally against some limits on
speech i don't think you ought to be
able to defraud people i don't think you
ought to be able to engage engage in
sedition
i don't think that you ought to be able
to engage in fighting words i don't
think you should be able to engage in
that stuff
however that
is a separate standard right what we're
really talking about here is not free
speech versus censorship
we're talking about two competing sets
of standards
ashley babbitt bobbitt babbitt what was
it
she was the woman who was killed during
the capitol hill riot
the doj has decided it will not seek
criminal charges into the shooting of
ashley babbitt
why not should
do we believe that the the officer who
killed ashley babbitt should be thrown
in jail
probably not uh you know was it an
excessive use of force maybe it was
they were entering into you know the
capital that's that's a big problem
so perhaps
uh you know you can you can look into
the issue one way or the other
my only my only issue here is we know
the name of the officer who killed dante
wright
we know the name of the officer who
killed george floyd
we don't know the name of the officer
who killed ashley babbitt
because it doesn't advance the narrative
doesn't advance
any sort of propaganda here that's a
double st that's the real standard that
we're living under
by the way we've got to uh report here
on florida some good news very rarely do
we get good news to end on
on monday florida state health officials
revealed
that the state has recorded a single
digit increase
in kovid 19 related deaths for the first
time in almost seven
months the state health department said
seven more floridians and two additional
non-residents have died due to covid 19.
very sad that these people have died
but pretty good that it is
so low but this doesn't make sense
florida's been open basically the whole
time
what's that about very very strange
stuff
quote over the past two weeks daily
reported coveted deaths across the state
have ranged between 22
and 98 not 2200 not 22 000 22 and 98
the week to week reported deaths have
been on a slow decline
since january just five new coronavirus
deaths in florida
were reported uh september 28th
wow that's pretty great
can't beat that stuff folks so
that's the good news you're not going to
hear that from the mainstream media
you're not going to hear that from
cnn because they are going to be pushing
propaganda where there's a lot of big
money and a lot of big power perhaps we
should try to take that power back i'm
michael knowles this is michael noel
show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show president biden
and his top staffers continue to lie
like a rug about endemic american racism
prosecutors declined to charge a cop in
the death of ashley babbitt while moving
forward with charges against a cop
in the death of dante wright and the
activist media moved to pressure
corporations to echo
the racial resentment politics of the
democratic party there's a lot there
tune in you'll enjoy it